at least 36 people including 24 children
have been killed in a shooting in
Northeast Thailand it happened at a
daycare center in Nong bua lampu Fenton
Monaghan has more
the aftermath of a mass shooting that's
shaken Thailand dozens of people killed
at a children's daycare center about 500
kilometers Southwest of Bangkok many
children were among the dead some as
young as two years old at this point
it's time to really start looking at the
issue of how many guns are in Thailand
there are many registered and
unregistered guns the country is
basically Awash in them and so it's a
bit surprising that only in the last
couple years are we seeing these kind of
mass shooting incidents
the gunman was a former police officer
after opening fire in the daycare center
he returned home where he killed his
wife and child before taking his own
life
Mr prayer Channel described the attack
as shocking
he offered condolences to victims and
ordered emergency services to do all
they can for the wounded
questions remain as to what led to this
attack and what motivated the Killer
and parents grieving their loss will be
demanding answers Benton Monaghan Al
Jazeera
well let's go live to altazira's Tony
Chang who is in Bangkok for us uh Tony
any more details about casualties uh or
victims
at this stage the authorities are
sticking with a total of 36 fatalities
including 24 children
and 12 people wounded in the attacks we
understand seriously wounded they say
the chief suspect had been attending a
court hearing in the morning on the
drugs charge a drugs charge that had
seen him ejected from his job as a
policeman
after that he went to the daycare center
to collect his son not finding him there
he then opened fire on those inside we
understand he then fled in a white
pickup truck attacking people on the way
to his home where as you heard he killed
his wife and son and then himself
at this stage very hard to determine
what the motive was from the attack but
the police are saying he had a troubled
record in the police force before he was
fired for uh reasons relating to drug
use
um I think it will be very shocking to
many people involved that so many
children have been killed in this attack
in a country where really the life of
children is very valued as of course it
is in most other places but I think
that's a huge shock here all over the
country no I'm sure and uh around the
world of course too
um Al jazeera's Tony Chang there for us
in Bangkok